hey theo this is adam from salt lake
again man um
also i i forgot to ask you um
adam thank you for calling man and salt
lake is real good man
if you like looking at white people dude
you
will love it oh
i've been up and then them dark arts you
know
i was wondering too i forgot to ask you
like
like i've been i've been trying to look
around
for for some aaa's and uh some m a
meetings like like what what do you look
for in
in going into an aaa where you can
really
kind of feel comfortable about what you
want to talk talk about and uh
thank you for the call man this is a
cool question
my experience with going into an aaa
meeting
or my suggestion i would offer to
anybody who asked about it would be
go to three meetings try out three
different ones
make sure that one of them is a speaker
meeting where somebody is speaking for
like an extended period of time
it could be 10 minutes or 15 minutes or
sometimes it's 30 minutes
40 minutes but you want to hear
somebody's story
uh and then try some other ones try one
that's a co-ed try one that's maybe just
men or women
if you're one of the other um
and
uh and now and then and then make a
decision for yourself
just because they're different so you
want to get it they're not all the same
and i would just say listen for the
difference listen for the similarities
not the differences that's what they say
listen for the similarities and not the
differences
because it's easy for me a lot of times
to sit there and judge things
you know instead of be like what is
what am i okay with in here instead of
finding all the reasons already why i
can't stand
something because then i'm just not
giving myself a chance
but it's it's really interesting to go
to whether you feel like you have a
problem or not it's really interesting
to go to um
some type of 12-step meeting so best of
luck over there brother i'm sure there's
a lot of good ones in salt lake
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another
and you can watch this one you can watch
this one different options different
choices
some guy just brings you one option not
this guy
two options watch one this one or this
one